[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua phillips-milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists what is the number
one most requested topic that we have
not covered on the minimalist podcast
minimalist pets
i gotta tell you this is this question
we we get variations of pet questions
more than anything and we've waited
329 episodes
so look no further because today on the
public podcast on this minimal episode
that's exactly what we're talking about
we're talking about simple pets with dr
karen shaw becker and rodney habib
they're the authors of this new book let
me hold it up if you're watching on
youtube it's called the forever dog
we're gonna dive in to the book
and then on this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast we're going
to talk about how we've turned our cats
and dogs into hoarders
isn't it true
rodney karen thank you both for being
here really appreciate it thanks so much
for having us excited to be here man oh
man this is uh i'm telling you i i
usually record podcasts ryan and i
record podcasts where it's a topic i'm
really really interested in i don't have
a ton of interest in this topic
well you know we're known for being
honest so uh yeah josh just being honest
there but this is why it's the perfect
podcast because our audience is so
interested the questions keep pouring in
we have voicemails we have text messages
we have social media questions we always
have people asking us about pets i don't
own any pets i'm allergic to pets
literally and figuratively yes
but i i want to understand this
fascination because ryan has a pet i
have a child i don't think she counts as
having a pet though
not after they turn five
um but here's the thing we have so many
questions about this because this is a
listener driven show i thought we would
just dive right into the questions
and then we'll uh we'll just see where
that takes us our first question today
is from morgan on facebook
apart from working or service animals
why do humans need pets
why do we need now now karen is there
maybe there's a a biological or
evolutionary imperative here because
when i look at hunter-gatherers many of
them even have pets so so ancient human
beings we've had pets for a very long
time right humans and animals have
co-evolved totally and we have a special
affinity for
canis lupus familiaris domesticated dogs
which of course their cousins were gray
wolves and so humans and the grey wolf
had been co-evolving for
for millennia which is awesome
it served us because wolves were uh you
know they were basically scavenged on
our garbage tens of thousands of years
ago so we throw the garbage out they
would forage but we ended up working
together wolves uh and and then of
course domesticated dogs they're amazing
to be around they offer some protection
we can hunt together with them but then
we realized how cool they were as
species as as animals
and over the last 10 000 years they went
from
us hanging out with them to
then us using dogs for working purposes
to then us breeding specific types of
dogs to serve a purpose dogs that
retrieve things in water dogs that can
retrieve pheasants dogs that can flush
pheasants
to dogs that were just cute and adorable
and then they came closer they went from
the barn to the front porch and from the
front porch to our beds and there they
have stayed the last couple hundred
years um that's awesome yeah i i it
amazes me how
we have evolved dogs to do specific
things
and i forget who i was like i don't know
i'm telling my little cousin this i was
like you know dogs like they they come
from wolves and like she just couldn't
wrap her head around it and i'm like no
thousands of years of breeding like you
get this little chihuahua
and when you see a chihuahua next to
wolf you're like that these can't
possibly this could not have derived
from this right but ronnie back to the
question
it's not that we need pets i think quite
often it's that people get great joy
from having a companion man i kind of
like i'm kind of i was kind of like you
so initially dogs are kind of new to me
per se came from mediterranean family
family was like nope absolutely no dogs
are coming into the house the furniture
is number one you're gonna get dog hair
on the furniture we'll throw you outside
no dogs are coming in here so i man i
didn't get my first thought till my 30s
so that term hedonic adaptation you know
where you
i was
sheltered from that experience and then
the moment that my first dog came into
my life
it was the most life i changed my whole
career path i changed my entire life
when i got my first dog in my 30s
it was a white shepherd called sam it
was it was kind of really of a petty way
of to do it i watched the movie i am
legend with will smith he had a dog a
german shepherd in there named sam i had
to have a dog german shepherd named sam
is terrible i don't ever recommend
anyone
do not do that
but i will tell you holy moly like it
totally transformed my life like that i
can't explain the connection without
getting emotional and i think it's like
the mother when she has her first child
of the dad when they have their first
kid and you're kind of looking to that
child's eyes that i don't know that
connection i don't have kids
but if you talk to any pet parent in the
world
it's that same emotional connection and
then you're seeing a global
transformation from it right the birth
rate in america down 11 percent more
more moms are not becoming like kid moms
but they're like dog moms right in
certain countries there's more children
there's more pets than there are
children canada's getting there very
close the united states you're seeing
booms in places like china like there
was no dogs in china and then all of a
sudden over the last like decade they
are now the number one country in the
world with dogs and then you're watching
go to india and it's it's
a giant wave and i truly believe it's
because of that connection and the
completion that there is there you you
know you talk to a war veteran right
they'll tell you their whole life
changed when they got their service dog
right like it just totally transformed
them autistic children children now that
can read better or
prevent depression in kids because they
got somebody to talk to man i really
wish i could explain that feeling but if
you're a pet parent you know what i'm
talking about because it's you can feel
it on the inside yeah isn't it wild like
we have a pet like my wife and i have a
cat
and i love making that cat's life as as
amazing as i possibly can like there's
something about giving that cat a good
life that like really brings me joy and
it's the same thing with a dog i used to
have a dog and it was the same way it's
like taking him for a walk just every
time he got excited i got excited there
is like a connection with animals that
um that most yeah most people have i
think that's why we have pets for that
companionship it seems to me karen that
there is a biological imperative as well
for just connection and and we've
disconnected ourselves so much that
quite often we're also leaning on our
pets for that sort of emotional support
as well and that that emotional
connection instead of coming home to an
empty house by ourselves we're looking
for companionship however we can and and
one way to do that it seems is
to have a pet there and animals are so
authentic and they're so transparent and
they're so in the moment so when you go
out to get your mail or take the trash
out and you come in your dog is like
hello it's been 30 seconds and they're
so fired up your home like that is a
genuine reaction you don't get that from
your wife
you don't i mean you just don't
but let me tell you animals do that and
and it that brings us joy
yeah yeah they don't they don't lie like
it's almost like animals are incapable
of lying so yeah when they're when
they're happy to see you like you know
they are genuinely happy to see you oh
man this is making me want to get a
little dog
start with a little dog
has been talking about it for a while
it is it is no question i think you know
the best way to answer that question is
i believe because it it completes humans
there's no question about it that
there's just that lego piece like that
ideal perfect lego piece and you know
they don't ask anything of us except for
a little bit of food maybe a little bit
of water but that's it they don't ask
anything right and dogs live in the now
right we're always constantly thinking
about sort of the future and all what's
tomorrow going to be like and oh gosh i
lost my email this is the worst day of
my whole world i was typing it halfway
but the dog i mean especially depending
on some of the breeds i mean like a
golden retriever man like happy 24 7.
best energy 24 7. and the transformation
dr karen becker says all the time right
it's health traveling up the leash what
dogs can do for us
in return i mean harvard university was
just recently wrote a giant article
about it extends lifespan owning a dog
according to science can extend your
lifespan for a multitude of reasons very
cool well let's talk about because you
just said they don't ask for much they
ask for a little bit of food and water
but we fail
miserably at just feeding our pets
and i think quite a bit quite a bit of
it is because of ignorance we we just we
see the commercial here's the cheap food
i buy a dollar worth of food a week and
my pet should be fine right but they're
not really thriving it seems to me
that's why you wrote this book too yeah
we wrote this book for a lot of
different reasons but the
the big kind of coming together was as a
proactive wellness veterinarian i am
seeing my own
patients not live as long as healthfully
as they should certainly
but across the board we have a worldwide
epidemic of animals
not thriving and the question for me is
why is that why are animals not as
helpful living as healthfully as they
should they have more disease processes
more degeneration
more lifestyle-related diseases than
ever before but they're also not living
as long as they should and we heard
about all these outlier dogs some of
these dogs living you know early
twenties mid-twenties late twenties
thirty-year-old dogs everyone is like
listen we gotta go find these dogs and
find out what are they doing are they
outliers or are these owners doing
something intentional to create
thirty-year-old dogs so we just wanted
to find out what the scoop was so we
went on a mission to do it yeah there's
an acronym in the book dogs yeah can you
talk about what that acronym
it represents really brilliant acronym
i mean and i'd love to take full credit
for it uh but somebody's a little bit
smarter with the acronyms over here uh
so yeah so we broke it down like how can
we explain longevity because you're
going to write a book first of all and
you're going to tell people that you
know the longest lived dog 30 that we
know of that we got to sit down with and
you know as dr becker alluded to the 27
year old dogs and so on and so forth but
then you look here in north america and
the average lifespan today of a typical
dog is you're lucky might be 10 or 11.
yeah so it's like man how did like where
did i miss out on that right so we know
that diet is a major major part of it
obviously right i've listened to
multiple podcasts or you've talked about
your wife as a dietitian and and how
important health and nutrition is holy
moly is it ever it's if not equally more
important in the pet space as well but
just people don't have that mindset and
that knowledge so we said okay right off
the bat d is going to be for diet right
because that is yes if you got that on
lock down you're almost there right
let's say one quarter of the way there
um o for optimal movement exercise we
all know how critical exercise is g
genetics man
i can't even tell you what we've done to
dogs over the last one 100 years over
genetics everybody wants that designer
breed
what are you really getting genetically
speaking right so we we dive really deep
into genetics and then s
for me maybe one of the most eye-opening
experiences i've ever had when we got to
sit down with some of the world's top
longevity experts to break it down for
us stress
and not just stress by like your
day-to-day stress but we broke it into a
couple categories like chemical stress
what are the things that we are putting
on our pets what are like the
ramifications from that right you have
physical stress you have emotional
stress
so that was kind of sort of the
breakdown of the
dogs strategy because we didn't want
people at the end of the day to say hey
i looked in the book i saw the one of
the oldest live dogs was eating carrots
i gave my dog carrots he didn't live to
be 30 you guys suck
we really had a lot of other factors
yeah 100 and i think i think we'll dive
a little bit deeper into the acronym
especially the diet side of things
because i want to talk about what it
means to eat healthfully we got some
other questions here um shout out to our
patreon live stream we usually do a
patreon live stream for this but we
already did one this week but we do have
a question from patreon from
hannah by the way hannah thank you for
keeping our podcast 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck yeah they do looks
like hannah has a question for us how
many pets is too many for a minimalist
four
next question
you know what is interesting i think
this is it's like that's like asking how
many how many items is too many or how
many children is too many right
because it's all perspectival so uh we
have a friend leo babalta who first
turned us on to minimalism many years
ago
he and his wife had six kids he's the
ultimate minimalist
but
he still has a ton of kids six kids
would be totally inappropriate for me
right and so understanding what is
appropriate for you
one pet might be too many for you or
three might not be enough
that is exactly right it depends on you
your lifestyle your job how much how can
you afford to appropriately nourish them
care for them do you have the time all
of those factors so to answer her
question
it's
you need to make sure that you can
assure yourself that you are giving
every animal in your care the very best
life physically emotionally that you are
doing everything you can to to make sure
that you're doing your part as a
guardian and that's from birth until the
day that that animal dies so it's a
lifelong commitment that you have to be
prepared for so it's not about a number
it's about are you doing
excellent service to the animals that
you have committed to care for and
that's your first priority and you don't
keep adding more animals if you do not
have the time resources energy focused
to be able to love and support them
completely for their whole life yeah oh
man i think i was watching this show uh
called the kindness diaries and this guy
drives around in a car with no cash and
he just like sees how he can like live
with no money at all and that's you know
relying on the kindness of strangers is
a whole idea well there was this
particular uh woman in mexico i think
who had i want to say like like a huge
500 acre like lot and had like a
thousand dogs and she just like rescued
as many dogs as possible
and i would still consider her a
minimalist i mean if that's if that's
the lifestyle she was living you could
have a thousand dogs she had the room
for it
and what he would do in return is like
he would basically do something for the
community or do something for that
person like when they you know would
give him an act of kindness he ended up
feeding them for i forget how many
months or something but uh but yeah it's
uh there's no number to put on it for
sure it's it's yeah the quality of
lifestyle like that's that's really what
you want to look at you mentioned
genetics earlier rodney and i'll tell
you man i have seen like some dogs i
really feel sorry like these little
teacup chihuahuas i've seen probably
three four or five i've never seen like
a super healthy
teacup chihuahua their tongue's hanging
out they have like eyeballs popping out
of it yeah
look how cute yes
it was it's a huge problem especially
today they call it you know during the
puppy pandemic stage right because
everybody wanted a dog we watched like
rates like skyrocket right really
there's some so some shelters will tell
you we're completed of dogs which is
awesome right right this isn't this
doesn't it's not a like a perfect
through line did not happen everywhere
in every single location but in a lot of
locations right a lot lots of like news
media releases that a lot of these
shelters are out of dogs
a lot of breeders now have more demand
on dogs so there's like a such a a
demand for dogs that now like it's
almost like breeders are just like
popping them out like tic tacs man right
and so but you don't know exactly
two pet parents super pumped you get
your dog you come home a year later
because this is a puppy it's small it's
tiny it's developing you're not really
100 sure what you got let's just say you
went for i don't know golden retriever
let's say hypothetically and then like
six months in you're like is that a
golden retriever right that doesn't kind
of look like a golden retriever to me
right but you're already six months in
it's like with your child you develop
this bond one year later you're like i'd
take her back
excuse me this baby is defective what is
this gonna be nine this year i'll still
take her back
so yeah you're into it you're like
that's not a golden 100 right and so
these are these puppy scams so these
dogs are coming from different parts of
the world it's kind of terrible yeah but
genetics when you're talking about
genetics you know we're always told that
you need like a good set of genes will
take you a long way right how about that
guy that you know smokes until he's like
a hundred and drinks whiskey until he's
100 and then you've got this epic pillar
of health on the other side like his
polar opposite let's say his brother and
he dies at like
60 of a heart attack meanwhile the
drinker and the smoker list to be 100
right we know that genetics plays a huge
role here same thing in the dog world
what what's happening though um aside
from these like puppy
this puppy pandemic problem where people
are going home with the wrong breed or
genetically malfunctioned dogs dr karen
becker talks about it all the time
there's this term called like genetic
deletion where you can come home with a
dog that's missing a specific gene for
like eye health you spend the rest of
your life spending money like at an
optometrist veterinary optometrist
spending money on vet bills or you go
home that a dog missing a gene for a
specific function or like proper heart
health so the dog develops like dilated
cardiomyopathy in the future so genetics
is so important because you can do all
of the most perfect things as a pet
parent like literally go from like a to
z be the most like quintessential pet
parent in the entire world but the dog
had a set of genetics that you couldn't
control or you rescue a dog from a
shelter you can't do anything about
those genetics right right right but so
really to take home messages if you're
going to spend money there are millions
of dogs dying and dying in shelters
around the world they're really we have
an overpopulation problem so i'm a big
believer
if you can rescue an animal please do
however if you're gonna you're gonna
spend cash if you're gonna shell out
money on life
you wanna make sure that you are buying
amazing genetics that you are supporting
ethical breeders and breeders trying to
diversify and make their breed more
resilient that they're doing dna testing
to check for genetic deletions that
they're doing everything they can to
produce incredibly healthy litters but
those breeders are actually really hard
to find backyard breeders puppy mills
way easier and because people
want a dog so bad when they decide okay
i'm getting one
they will go to a pet store they'll buy
puppies out of someone's car in a
parking lot they'll say you know what
someone has to rescue this dog and i've
had so many clients say i didn't want to
buy a puppy mill dog but i wanted a
puppy now
and what i tell my clients
is just like adopting a child you would
not just go to some shady backyard
whatever and you know get a kid because
the kid could be trafficked right you
just don't do that you have to you have
to go the legal ways and make sure that
you are doing things ethically morally
correctly
and if you want to pay money for a dog
you really want to make sure that your
breeder is stellar and that you've done
your homework and that you've asked you
know we have a 21 question breeder
questionnaire in the book that you want
to ask really detailed questions and you
want to make sure that you're getting
the responses you want from that reader
so that you know in your heart you're
paying for a puppy that's not going to
deliver a massive heartbreak to you
later on now once you have a pet
i want to talk about what is in our
control so their diet and exercise which
are two very broad terms we recognize
that that dogs who are just trapped in a
studio apartment all day may not be
thriving in terms of their mobility i
think that's relatively obvious the
thing that's less obvious is the food
that we feed to our dogs so when you
talk about feeding your dogs healthfully
or cats as well feeding your pets
healthfully
well what's uh what does that really
look like
yeah here lies the
million-dollar dilemma that we were
facing when we were first getting into
this conundrum right because
look convenience is one thing because
one of the scary things for like a
first-time pet parent is what on earth
am i going to feed this dog i have no
idea what i'm supposed to feed a dog
it's almost like bringing home like a
baby alien right like i don't know what
he's supposed to eat right cornmeal you
know cornmeal
cornmeal and soy yeah so like obviously
you have to rely on somebody so for
first-time pet parents they're going to
allow the manufacturer to you know
produce something for them that they
believe is going to be healthy
one of our challenges when it comes to
the term food is we we live in a polar
opposite world
so human science nutrition and animal
science nutrition are upside down
and they don't need to be but they are
because of perception and you know that
term perception is copper coupled to
reality right
we perceive
ultra-processed diets foods that are
shelf-stable that can sit on shelves for
years without rotting to be science and
health
in a pet shop
but when you go to the grocery store and
there's those same type of foods that
come out through an extruder you got to
get this play-doh mix that you know with
these oils and gels and they get punched
out of like this little
hole that comes out and dies and they
start chopping them into these like
little tiny pellets well we know that's
extrusion in the human field in the
human world there's something innate
inside of you that looks at that and
this uh you know that i don't know if
that's going to be really good for me
i you know i should be in the in the in
the what they say the outer aisles in
the grocery store like where you get the
fresh greens and so on and so forth i'm
shopping kind of in the middle aisle
you know that inside of you
but in the animal space in animal
science nutrition
doctors veterinarians
breeders people are told ultra processed
food is science ultra processed food is
healthier this is what you should be
feeding if you go to your refrigerator
and you pull a carrot out of your
refrigerator you feed it to your dog or
your cat
ryan
you'll give it diarrhea
stick with the ulcer processed food it's
better for your pet your pet will live a
lot longer we're the only as
veterinarians we're the last remaining
group of health and wellness
professionals to advocate
eating entirely processed food from
birth till death veterinarians are i
mean pediatricians say hey parents feed
your kids some more fresh food try and
get some living foods in
in the u.s about 50 of calories for
humans come from ultra processed foods a
day but that means the other 50 we're
eating some living food some some
recognizable food we're like oh look i
can identify what that food is
animals eat ultra processed little brown
crunchy balls from the day that they're
weaned to the day that they die and lots
of pet parents have never thought about
giving anything other than pet food
because
my profession included will say never
never feed anything but these little
crunchy pellets and we do find it
interesting we talk a lot about in the
book how that got started but the fact
is kibble
feeding your kids to the dollar menus
super fast the kids don't argue it's
cheap and everyone's happy in the car
but they are not well nourished they're
full but they're not well nourished
the same epidemic is happening with our
companion animals they are being fed
they're obese
they're they have massive lifestyle
related diseases we have more allergies
autoimmune disease more cancer more
diabetes than ever before
and yet
we're not necessarily having the
correlation to food conversation and
that was the other half of the reason
that we wrote the book we wanted people
to recognize what's happening here and
then most importantly have a path to fix
it
and these healthy dogs who live the
longest it seems to me that they're
they're eating
well they're eating real food they're
eating i mean the our pets cats in
particular but even dogs are carnivorous
animals they eat meat and
the to eat meat in its roleless form is
where they're going to get the most you
know b vitamins and nutrients etc that
is all cooked out processed out of that
that food that you're talking about and
this is where we needed to turn to the
human space when we were going to do
this we knew that we were going to hit
dead ends man if we were going to look
to the science community in the animal
world because where are all the studies
in the research and the data coming up
well it comes from big pet food those
are people that can kind of afford it
right those like top three companies are
also the top three companies in the
confectionary space in the human space
right
so it's hard to you know it's hard to
when you go through the grocery store
it's kind of interesting you know when
you look at the levels of food right so
somebody would say to himself okay well
i can only spend this much money so i'm
gonna go to the grocery store to buy my
food oh i got a little bit more money i
can go down to the pet specialty store
down the street oh i got a lot of money
i'll just go buy it from my vet clinic
because it's like the best food all made
by the same manufacturer yeah
same stuff bottom to top right so this
is kind of like that oh my gosh
experience so when you try to go
into the literature into science and you
say okay let's write this book let's
talk about you know health let's talk
about uh you know nourishments and
phytochemicals and and polyphenols and
so on and so forth if you spend some
time in pubmed it's all done on ultra
processed food so ultra processed food
diet a we sprinkled some polyphenols on
it and we saw some great success so
let's put some polyphenol powder on the
ultra processed food diet and we're
seeing some benefit well who's doing the
studies on like whole foods here like
who's doing that so
one of the big challenges for us was
like okay let's get on a plane
you know when you if you want to be a
millionaire sit down and talk to a
millionaire don't sit down you know in
the bar with that guy that's got those
millionaire ideas who's like dead broke
by the way can you help pay for my beer
for me
where are you gonna get your advice from
let's go out let's sit down with some of
these extraordinary pet parents that
have raised the most extraordinary dogs
and cats dogs to be in their 30s jake
perry who's raised back to back guinness
world book of record cats set the
guinness world book record once at their
34 year old cat second time at a 38 year
old cat those are the people you got to
talk to so what are you guys doing yeah
and rather than we say hey okay let's
break down and give our thoughts of
course our thoughts are in the book but
let's go to the top scientists like
at some point some of these guys like dr
david sinclair from harvard university
dr like valder longo uh dr sachin panda
from the salk institute let's go like
who's gonna battle those guys come on
like somebody in the big pet food
industry wants to battle those guys no
let's go to these human longevity
experts help them break down why they
think these dogs live so long why they
feel feeding fresh whole food can be
done and how can we take that data
and put it together in a book bite size
for a pet parent whether you're 20 year
old living in la or whether you're 80
year old living up in canada everyone
will be able to break it down easily
what's beautiful about this is
well we're accidentally causing a lot of
suffering in other animals we don't
intend to in fact our intentions are the
exact opposite i'm going to take in this
animal
because i want to care for them i want
to provide them a better life not
knowing what we're doing to them is
causing disease and misery and suffering
and i want to acknowledge you for
writing this book because really what
we're talking about here is easing that
suffering or eliminating the suffering
through very simple
we're not talking about some elaborate
thing in fact it's it's actually getting
back
to
nature to to what pets eat and how they
move right and even back to their
genetics understanding that what we're
doing with breeding pets is causing a
lot of suffering as well ryan i want to
move on to some callers here if you have
a question or comment for our podcast
give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com looks like
we have a question here from jyn in
albany new york i have five children and
a husband and um we have a family dog
the dog i believe adds value to
my life and to the kid's life but my
husband unfortunately is not um not
getting value out of the dog's presence
and
you know the dog is doing stuff like you
know making holes in the yard and
preventing his um
garden from thriving
um we have like a perimeter collar on
him so he can only go in certain places
um but the garden is in the front yard
and i feel like having the dog in the
front yard his presence is important
um just from a safety perspective you
know um
to keep uh people from feeling too
comfortable walking up to the house so
in that respect i i get value out of his
presence as well
um but my husband's really frustrated
because he's you know um he wants his
garden to look nice
um
i guess that's a dilemma you know like
it what do you do when when um
your
values are uh contradictory
so you know what's fascinating here jen
is i totally
completely
resonate with your husband
and
and my family like my daughter in
particular would love to have a dog we
live in an apartment it just wouldn't
make a whole lot of sense i don't think
for for us at least not not currently
but
there is a particular burden here
because it's not just about taking care
of the dog it's the the suffering that
this dog is inflecting on the husband by
trampling the garden whatever and so
they are at a bit of an impasse do we
have any thoughts for jen and her family
well a couple of different thoughts from
my perspective i have no idea jen how
much exercise your pooch is getting but
let me say this dogs all dogs are wired
as athletes
and dogs neat a lot of people think that
i'm just gonna let my dog in the yard
and you know it's beautiful they'll be
able to move around and there's a bunch
of sensory stimulation everything will
be fine dogs get bored quickly and they
will create their own parties digging is
a good example of a dog that's like
there's not much going on out here
i really don't have much to do i think
i'm just gonna dig a bunch of big holes
in the yard now
you can train dogs you can give your dog
an appropriate digging pit so you can
give him one area and that's where he
needs to dig
but getting your dog nice and tired on a
daily basis running your dog to
exhaustion every day allowing your dog
to move his body off lead and get all of
his energy out it's like a little kid
you have to allow them to burn up energy
and move their bodies that's a great way
for you to get exercises yeah and your
five kids yes
share the responsibilities built-in dog
babysitters right there
each kid takes an hour that's 500
actually the dog will be so tired he
will not be able to dig in the yard so
we do have to say dogs a lot of people
assume that their dogs are mentally
enriched and that they have a beautiful
life and really their dogs are bored
stiff i'm not insinuating that jen but a
lot of people say i have a lot of kids
the dog is going to be active the dog is
naturally happy a lot of dogs and big
families are board stiffed and create
their own parties by misbehavior
so i would say exercise first of all
second thing i would do is if your
husband can recognize especially if the
dog will self-forage out of the garden
if you plant an extra 10 for the dog to
be able to participate and choose foods
from the garden you can grow food for
your dog that your dog will be able to
select in essence it becomes a sensory
herb nourishment garden that includes
providing enough fruits and veggies for
your dog now the husband may say i'm
interested in doing that but if he could
include the dog as a part of growing the
garden and then of course training there
has to be some training involved you
might be able to begin to co-exist with
the dog in a way that allows him to
exist in the yard without wanting to
trample the garden because he's bored
stiff while working on training but
getting your dog good and tired on a
daily basis is one of the most important
things to prevent boredom-based
behaviors around the house oh my god
karen you should be like a marriage
counselor this is uh this is great
advice for jen and her husband because
well here's the thing with any
relationship right there's got to be a
little bit of give and take a little bit
of a compromise which i don't know why
but when i say compromise it sounds like
negative but there is like that's just
how it is in a relationship like you've
got to figure out what each other's
preferences are values are and you got
to meet in the middle somewhere
sometimes and what you've done is you've
given jen an action item like hey here's
what you can do to help the dog and
you've also given her husband something
that hey here's what your husband can do
and like this will alleviate some of
that stress you're feeling around the
dog so um yeah you should yeah maybe you
look into marriage counseling that's
great
all right i want to move on to one more
question for this minimal episode what
time is it you know what time it is it's
time for the lightning round where we
answer your text messages you can text
your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 now rodney karen this is
where we do our best to answer questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response but not really we
just ramble on a little bit podcast sean
tweezes something out that's pithy and
he puts it in the show notes we call
them minimal maxims uh you can copy and
spread our minimal maxims on social
media if you like you can find them in
the show notes or you can find all of
our minimal maximums in one place
minimalmaxims.com
looks like eden has a question for us
alabama i love the cat i adopted
recently but now everyone's giving me
cat themed gifts how do we continue to
be a proud pet guardian without it
becoming our entire identity isn't this
interesting because it does become part
of our identity sometimes i am this type
of person whatever it is here's my job
title on business card i am a cat person
i am a dog person i am whatever and we
get so caught up in that identity it's
and now people try to reinforce that
identity through a bunch of well you
know excess
what do you got what do you got
i i have to say this to my clients all
the time my beautiful clients and they
want to gift me all sorts of
things yeah and that's great i just say
listen thank you so much i you plea
please don't please don't in her
situation i would say listen i love my
cat i'm all things cat i'm a crazy cat
person however i don't want crazy cat
stuff
um i just believe in being really honest
with everyone who is trying to give me
more and more stuff that i don't have a
place for i am honest with my clients
and say thank you so much i am not
interested my clients are aware at this
point now that i'm not a gift girl that
so thank you so much um thank you no
my problem is my genetics i'm canadian
so like i'm just like thank you right
right or sorry right you're right
i
i i just don't have a genetically
decided somebody to give me something
and i give it back even if i didn't want
to get it but you know there's some
really cool things that you can do
maybe with those items
man there's a lot of rescues and
shelters that really could use money and
they're always doing auctions right
i don't know how awesome it would be if
somebody gave me a gift and they were
saw it on facebook trolling around
somewhere that it was being auctioned
but i mean you could do some really you
could do some real good with some of the
gifts that people give me so i know
sometimes i'll have something wait it
out a little bit i donated to a shelter
but i can go to like an awesome cause or
like cancer research or whatever the
case may be maybe you could turn that
gift into sort of transforming an
animal's life that would be my one
canadian type of idea that's beautiful
such a giving giving a heart over here
this canadian heart
well i i have just a comment about
identities and i you know we were sort
of talking about that for a second but
here's something pithy for you our our
identities are shaped by the stories we
tell ourselves so quite often we just
say well i am this type of person um and
unfortunately that becomes incredibly
limiting because then we get if you are
a cat person now i can't have a dog
right
no i'm just a cat person or uh in fact
we're going to talk about this on the
maximal episode this week i got the
story of jason and jennifer kirkendall
with their their cat and dog and um
we're gonna talk about that but you
become sort of constricted by the
limiting stories that you tell yourself
yeah you got something pithy for us
right i do and it has to do with
identity as well so our our identities
cannot hide us from ourselves so you
might not want to be a cat person but
maybe you are a cat person and that's
okay but just because you give yourself
a label it doesn't mean that all of a
sudden you're going to uh uh be that
type of person so yeah i'm not saying
that you are arnie cat person eden but
uh but if you are that's okay because i
know some people who are like
they they think of a cat person and
they're like oh i can never be a cat
person but really like
they would really get along well with
cats and that's that's okay yeah and
even with me i have that limiting belief
where like i'm not a pet person right
now part of it is i i do have out pet
allergies but there are you know hypo
allergenic and all these other things
right yes but the most limiting thing is
saying well i'm not that type of person
and in understanding you know what like
maybe there are some ways to get value
from this that i'm closing myself
off to
we got so much more to talk about but
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist it's a brand new
month and that means it's a brand new
opportunity to play the 30-day
minimalism game although you could do
this with your pet stuff too because on
the maximal this thursday over at
patreon we're going to talk about um oh
our pets are such hoarders now
so the average kid in america has about
300 toys but plays with only 12 of them
daily it feels like pets are the same
way except they play with about one toy
yeah what a great scapegoat though like
i'm not a hoarder my pet is
that's just
right
so here's how the 30-day minimalism game
works you partner up with someone a
friend a family member a co-worker a pet
and uh you decide to get rid of some
stuff that start at the beginning of the
month first day of the month you each
get rid of one item starts off really
easy get you that momentum you need
second day of the month two items third
day of the month three items so forth
and so on really really easy up front
but then it gets more difficult because
day 12 you're like oh crap i got to get
rid of a dozen things today
and it's all pet toys
and but then you know tomorrow i have to
get rid of 13 things and so whoever you
partner up with
well that you bet whatever you want you
can bet a dollar a nice meal you have to
watch my dog for a week whatever it
might be whoever goes the longest
throughout the month you win if you both
make it to the end of the month then
you've both won because you've gotten
rid of about 500 items that's a really
good start you can download a free
minimalist game calendar over on our
resources page the minimalists.com
resources you can also see a video we
did about the minimalist game over there
as well at the minimalists.com
game so it's a free game free calendar
you can download the minimalists.com
game alabama we got some more to talk
about what do you got for us first here
are some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners
hey josh and ryan this is kristen i
wanted to share a health tip with you
and your listeners every morning for
several years my routine has started
with a glass of hot water with half a
lemon squeezed in it hot water because
the molecules move faster and it acts
like a scrub brush through your
digestive system it's like a natural
cleanser that allows you to digest your
subsequent food and drinks throughout
the day more effectively and also so you
can absorb nutrients better it also
helps detoxify the liver and you can
metabolize and burn fat better and then
of course the vitamin c is a nice boost
to the immune system
hello this is sarah wilkinson from kent
in the uk
i have a photo tip i wanted to share
with fellow listeners on their own
minimalist journey i've discovered that
i personally really don't like to have
anything hung on the wall unless it has
sentimental value or practical use
which includes photographs
so i started making a calendar at the
end of every year which is filled with
photos of things i did and places i went
that year which i can reflect on over
the following year
not only does it remind me and
reinforce gratitude of what a great year
i had it also helps keep me organized
and actually encourages me to create new
experiences so that i can fill up my
calendar the next year
there are companies out there
where you can really personalize the
calendar i think this keeps a fresh
style and then obviously more
importantly
fresh photos
as you flip the calendar over every
month and then at the end of the year i
let go and recycle the calendar
all right y'all big thanks to our new
friends
rodney habib and dr karen becker their
book is called the forever dog
surprising new science to help your
canine companion live younger healthier
and longer you can also find them online
did you know that dr karen becker is the
most followed vet
on facebook so i'll put a link to her
facebook in the show notes also rodney
is the founder of planet poles he's a
blogger and public speaker you can find
all of his work over there at planet
polls we'll put a link to that in the
show notes as well
ryan for our added value this week since
we're talking about exotic pets on the
maxwell episode
one exotic pet is a bonobo you can keep
it but no i guess you can keep anything
as a pet technically you can keep
anything yeah uh but i i've been keeping
a child for years
but people actually keep bonobos as pets
i mean some people do very very few and
obviously uh dr becker she she is
against the exotic cats she'll go into
detail on why on the maximal episode
this week but my added value this week
is bonobo but it's a band called bonobo
oh they have a new album out the album
is called fragments and the title or the
opening track rather is a song called
polyghosts let's have a listen to that
now this album it's
a short album but it's sort of like this
bex and i were driving around yesterday
just listening to it and it's like
atmospheric cali vibes but it starts off
real like down tempo and then it becomes
real upbeat and and before you know it
you're all you're just dancing to it you
didn't didn't expect it at all but we're
going to ease you into it here's the
opening track
it's called polyghosts from bonobo's new
album fragments by the way ryan we have
a bunch more surprise questions this
week like
what do we do if we think someone might
be an animal hoarder what's the best way
to re-home your pet when you can no
longer care for them
is there any such thing as essential pet
gear
how do you plan end of life decisions
for your pets plus a million more
questions for karen rodney and the
minimalist said if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you also gain access to hundreds of
hours of private archives recordings of
live events exclusive home tours and our
private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers like you you can
follow the minimalists on tik-tok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalist if you want our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus
podcast sean alabama jordan no more
social just danny unknown emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team i'm
joshua fields milburn reminding you to
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it
everyone